Bryce Harper son to 330 million dollar
contract with the Philadelphia Phillies
can you imagine that money 330 million
with the do you go by four can you buy
Philadelphia for that you could at least
buy Punxsutawney PA and own that little
durable I would do with that much money
yeah how you not gonna do cocaine how
soon do you all want this guy doing
cocaine because you telling me this
Bryce Harper's gots 330 mm million
dollars dude there's no way I'm putting
1 million of that towards the great
white north you know what I'm saying
that [ __ ] knows Alaska baby nah
I'm [ __ ] that Pablo Escobar's baby I
buy a [ __ ] straight-up swig gallon of
cocaine have anybody ever bought a
gallon of cocaine because that's what I
would be oh yeah let me get a um glad
bag full of cocaine also fill up my
[ __ ] hat while you're at it just yeah
oh no don't feel it today or fill it put
that you know give me that mogul baby
throw that frickin us that [ __ ] dusty
snout chowder on there because I'm
looking for the Lord you feel me I think
it's too much money to give someone at
once
it doesn't seem safe so let's see what
happens to him Bryce Harper taking that
what I like to call the cocaine
challenge you got three hundred and
thirty million dollars
dude I would have a stripper dancing on
each shoulder a really small stripper
you know so you could just look over
like that
and smell em tap hands you feel me smell
them [ __ ] milk bungalows baby summon
us welcome to what I like to call the
cocaine challenge Bryce Harper you got
three hundred and thirty million dollars
there I get my nuts gold-plated boy when
I sat down you would hear a thing when I
sat in any chair like what was that
something wrong with the chair now
something's right with my nuts I've got
these 14-karat gonads bruh and daddy's
thing ready to do business good luck
Bryce Harper good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one